it was european club football showpiece
for too many it showed the football
experience at its worst
this was two hours before kickoff
fans complained of crushing as a police
line prevented them from approaching the
stadium when the crowd was allowed to
move the problem shifted closer to the
ground
uefa says that what happened then was
that fans who bought fake tickets caused
a build up at the liverpool end
what transpired was a robust police
operation that saw officers giving chase
and using tear gas
uefa said it was to disperse numbers
that had built up and to force them away
from the stadium
fans queuing to get in were caught up in
a chaotic scene what's going on
what is going on
absolutely shambolic
the french
the organization and uefa is just
horrendous we're getting tear gas we're
getting charged with shields it's an
absolute joke we go to anfield every
week and everything's fine who are they
chasing now a child it's an absolute
joke liverpool football club have issued
a statement saying they're hugely
disappointed with what happened here
they've called for a formal
investigation they say this is the
greatest match in european football and
supporters shouldn't have to put up with
what happened the red army left the stad
de france bound for a sunday parade
through liverpool they did after all win
a domestic double of trophies
it'll be a celebration to remember
after a night to forget
james matthews sky news in paris